change wives he ought to be dr. lives
change organizations guy via
organization
I might change the world
before coming to the GSB prida was
working at McKinsey and he also worked
at Mars he's going to be going to work
for KKR after he graduates but he's also
very passionate about the issue of
microfinance and in addition to the work
that he's done leading up to now he's
involved with some some other students
on an initiative to improve microfinance
in the world that's what he's going to
talk about today so friedel let's get me
we live in a world in which every other
child is born into poverty oral in which
one and a half billion people live in
extreme poverty a world in which even
here in the United States poverty is a
growing problem when I was born in
nineteen eighty four fifteen percent of
young households live below the poverty
line today that number is twenty-two
percent that's unacceptable to me I came
to understand a lot of the issues facing
individuals working their way out of
poverty while working with microfinance
banks in India I'd go with the loan
officers in their rickshaws on their
daily routes and we go to the clients in
the villages and these clients were so
warm and welcoming they'd invite us into
their home's 40 and over T we would talk
about their families their dreams their
aspirations and also learned about so
many of the issues they face day in and
day out as they work their way out of
poverty and during those conversations I
discovered something I discovered that
there was something common across all of
these families that had helped him take
that first step forward in moving their
way out of poverty and that was access
to affordable credit you may ask
yourself what could a small loan
possibly do my dad grew up in a small
town in India and during his breaks in
vacation he loved going my grandfather
to our small fruit and vegetable store
they get up every morning and they would
head over to the store open it up and my
dad followed my grandfather system so
we'd have mangoes in the back and
vegetables in the front and they set it
up and wait for customers to come
there's a pretty small store but my dad
had big dreams
that entrepreneurial spirit inside of
him was already growing he wanted to
make it the biggest fruit and vegetable
store in the whole town but they didn't
have access to access cash for capital
to invest into it so it stayed a
relatively small store which was enough
for their family of 10 when he turned 18
my dad had a chance to go to college but
the family didn't have enough to pay for
tuition so he borrowed from friends and
family to pay his way through school and
30 years ago when my parents had a
chance to come here to the United States
arrived with only twelve dollars in hand
but they borrowed from friends and
family to find a place to stay and look
for work and two years later when they
finally had a chance my dad to start his
own business he borrowed from friends
and family for that initial capital and
built up his business into a small
successful small business it was a small
loan that helped my dad get through
school and earn an education it was a
small loan to help my parents come here
to the United States build their own
business and live the American dream and
it was a small loan that in part is
responsible for why I'm here at the
Stanford GSB it's a long way to go from
that small fruit and vegetable store all
the way to Stanford University
microfinance was designed to bring these
opportunities to billions of people
worldwide over 600 million people over
the last few decades have been served by
microfinance with the opportunity to
have access to financial services and
yet billions of people continue to live
without access to affordable credit
there are three things that are really
holding back the full potential of
microfinance first interest rates are
prohibitively high clients still find
themselves in spirals of paying loan
after alone after alone without being
able to work their way out of poverty
second there's a lack of sharing of
information across banks so that banks
are operating in silos even though we
have tens of thousands of banks around
the world and third the speed of growth
of new banks has been too slow so that
still billions of people live without
access to financial services I'm
starting a company called lending safe
lending save is designed to solve these
three problems by creating an IT
system that will serve as the back end
of all microfinance banks to allow them
to do their operations but more
importantly for the first time Linden's
they will connect the network of
microfinance banks together so that
they're constantly communicating and
interacting with each other to solve
these three problems and unlock the full
potential of these small loans the first
problem in microfinance today has been
the that interest rates are
prohibitively high Maria lives in a
small town in Mexico and she had seen
several of her friends get microfinance
loans to build their own businesses and
help their family and she got excited
she wanted to build the business
knitting scarves and selling to the
village so she can help her family so
she goes to the local microfinance
institution and gets alone and the
microfinance bank is excited about Maria
she is passionate she is committed and
skilled so they give her alone at the
lowest possible interest rate they can
which is eighty percent a year Maria
takes that loan she's believing in
herself she knows that she can do well
but she's scared even though she's
bought equipment and material and
developed her business for a few months
she's vulnerable to any shock they may
come whether it's a health crisis or a
natural disaster she knows that the
slightest thing can get her into a
spiral of borrowing to pay off loans
over and over again it's not that these
microfinance banks are looking to charge
as high of a possible interest rate and
make lots and lots of profit in fact
their cost of borrowing is pretty high a
bank in India that needs short-term
capital for a few months to get through
a flood has a choice of either going to
local institutions that charge a very
high interest rate or not offering loans
at all when at the same time Grameen
Bank in Bangladesh has tens of millions
of dollars of excess capital at that
time but there's no system to connect
the two and a bank in Sri Lanka that
faces excess flooding from June July and
August every single year can't partner
with the bank in Russia that knows it
has snow storms from November December
and January year so that together they
can borrow at better rates the second
problem in microfinance is the lack of
sharing of information across banks
Rekha lives in a small town in India and
she had seen three of her friends get
loans to build their own shoemaking
business
so she goes to the local loan officer
and says I want to build the shoemaking
business as well I have the skills and
the knowledge on how to do it the loan
officer having seen three successful
clients before gives her alone and helps
her get through that process of starting
a business rekha build her business by
buying equipment and material she needs
goes to every training and service
offering that the microfinance bank has
but a few months later finds it she
doesn't have enough clients to sustain
her business that loan officer didn't
have access to tens of thousands of
examples of people just like Rekha and
villages really similar to hers he could
he or she couldn't access in real time
exactly the type of businesses that
reiko would be successful in and the
services that would help her even though
that knowledge existed in the network of
microfinance banks around the world the
third problem in microfinance has been
the slow growth of new banks embody
lives in a rural village in Kenya and he
has a small mango farm and he is excited
about growing this mango farm it's he
may be the best mango farmer you love me
and he goes his friends and family says
can I borrow a little to invest into my
farm and grow it to make it even larger
and his friends and family come back and
say Ahmadi we believe in you your
passion that you're excited we just
don't have the cash to loan to you right
now so he starts looking and looking and
looking and 450 miles around his farm he
can't find an institution to loan to him
at an affordable rate opening a
microfinance bank is expensive there are
tens of thousands to hundreds of
thousands of dollars in IT
infrastructure costs and personnel and
not only that when Ahmadi walks into the
microfinance bank they don't know if
he's simply borrowing to pay off another
loan and they're fearful for that and
this high cost and risk that's
associated with the bank makes it hard
for new microfinance banks to open and
so the high cost of interest rates the
lack of sharing of information across
banks and the slow growth of new banks
have held back microfinance from its
full potential lending save is designed
to solve these three problems at Linden
say we will create an
IT system that will serve as the entire
back-end infrastructure for a
microfinance bank using technology we
have here in Silicon Valley a bank will
be able to use the lending save software
to interact with their clients issue new
loans and collect payments but more
importantly the software will not be
just limited to that individual bank for
the first time a network of banks will
be created all using the same system so
that they're in constant communication
with each other the lend and safe system
will reduce interest rates so that that
bank in India that needs short-term
capital will instantly be connected with
Grameen Bank for access to that and
Grameen Bank will instantly be able to
evaluate the risk of that bank and that
bank in Sri Lanka will be partnered with
that bank in Russia so they can come
together inside the system to borrow at
lower costs and that lower costs can be
passed on to clients as lower interest
rates the lending safe system will also
enable real-time sharing of information
so that that loan officer when Rekha
comes to off to ask for a loan for a
shoe making business will be able to
evaluate her in real time and take the
different data points about her and
apply them and understand no it's not a
shoe making business for a village this
site that makes sense but in fact if you
use those skills in a belt making
business and these are the different
trainings that make sense for you based
on tens of thousands of examples around
the world that's the right thing there
would be actually he'll be able to do
and the and the lending safe system will
enable banks to grow at a speed that
we've never seen before gone are the
tens and hundreds of thousands of
dollars of fixed costs replaced with a
low monthly subscription to the lending
saved software and when ahmadi walks
into a new bank he can be assured that
he all the microfinance banks will be
working on a similar system so he's
built up a credit history and that bank
will know that Amati is credit worthy
and can invest into his mango farm the
leaded safe system will reduce interest
rates it will allow for real-time
sharing of information across banks and
it allow banks to grow at a speed that
we've never seen before to unlock the
potential of these small loans my family
was fortunate
have access to friends and family to
help them take advantage of
opportunities that were presented and I
know that's not the case for everyone
but I'm hopeful I'm hopeful that
together we can build the lead and safe
system I'm hopeful that the lending save
system can bring access to affordable
credit to billions of people worldwide
and I'm hopeful that access to
affordable credit can be that first step
forward in reversing the course of
poverty today i'm building the lend and
safe team we're looking for investors to
fund it team members and developers to
build it and advisors to guide us if you
yourself or someone you know is one of
these three join us at london save calm
together we can build lend and safe and
take that first step forward to
reversing the course of poverty one
small loan at a time thank you very much